what impressive thing is biology doing
to you that computers are not yet
that Gap I would say I'm definitely on
I'm much more hesitant with the
analogies to the brain than I think he
would see potentially in the field
um and I kind of feel like
certainly the way neural network started
is everything stemmed from inspiration
of the by the brain but at the end of
the day the artifacts that you get after
training they are arrived at by a very
different optimization process than the
optimization process that gave fries to
the brain and so I think uh
I kind of think of it as a very
complicated alien artifact
um it's something different sorry the uh
the neuralness that we're training okay
they are complicated uh Alien artifact
uh I do not make analogies to the brain
because I think the optimization process
that gave rise to it is very different
from the brain so there was no
multi-agent self-play kind of uh setup
uh and evolution it was an optimization
that is basically a what amounts to a
compression objective on a massive
amount of data okay so artificial neural
networks are doing compression
and biological neural networks
are not to survive and they're not
really doing any they're they're an
agent in a multi-agent self-place system
that's been running for a very very long
time that said Evolution has found that
it is very useful to to predict and have
a predictive model in the brain and so I
think our brain utilizes something that
looks like that as a part of it but it
has a lot more you know gadgets and
gizmos and value functions and ancient
nuclei that are all trying to like make
it survive and reproduce and everything
else and the whole thing through
embryogenesis is built from a single
cell I mean it's just the code is inside
the DNA and it just builds it up like
the entire organisms
yes and like it does it pretty well
it should not be possible so there's
some learning going on there's some
there's some there's some kind of
computation going through that building
process I mean I I don't know where
if you were just to look at the entirety
of history of life on Earth where do you
think is the most interesting invention
is it the origin of life itself
is it just jumping to eukaryotes is it
mammals is it humans themselves Homo
sapiens the the origin of intelligence
or highly complex intelligence
or is it all just in continuation the
same kind of process
certainly I would say it's an extremely
remarkable story that I'm only like
briefly learning about recently all the
way
from
um actually like you almost have to
start at the formation of Earth and all
of its conditions and the entire solar
system and how everything is arranged
with Jupiter and Moon and the habitable
zone and everything and then you have an
active Earth
that's turning over material
and um and then you start with a
biogenesis and everything and so it's
all like a pretty remarkable story I'm
not sure that
I can pick like a single Unique Piece of
it that I find most interesting
um
I guess for me as an artificial
intelligence researcher it's probably
the last piece we have lots of animals
that uh you know are are not building
technological Society but we do and um
it seems to have happened very quickly
it seems to have happened very recently
and uh something very interesting
happened there that I don't fully
understand I almost understand
everything else it's kind of I think
intuitively uh but I don't understand
exactly that part and how quick it was
both explanations would be interesting
one is that this is just a continuation
of the same kind of process there's
nothing special about humans that would
be deeply understanding that would be
very interesting that we think of
ourselves as special but it was obvious
all it was already written in the in the
code that you would have
greater and greater intelligence
emerging and then the other explanation
which is something truly special
happened something like a rare event
whether it's like crazy rare event like
uh Space Odyssey what would it be see if
you say like the invention of Fire
or
the uh as Richard rangham says the beta
males deciding a clever way to kill the
alpha males by collaborating so just
optimizing the collaborations really the
multi-agent aspect of the multi-agent
and that really being constrained on
resources and trying to survive
the collaboration aspect is what created
the complex intelligence but it seems
like it's a natural outgrowth of the
evolution process like what what could
possibly be a magical thing that
happened like a rare thing that would
say that humans are actually human level
intelligence is actually a really rare
thing in the universe
yeah I'm hesitant to say that it is rare
by the way but it definitely seems like
it's kind of like a punctuated
equilibrium where you have lots of
exploration and then you have certain
leaps sparse leaps in between so of
course like origin of life would be one
um you know DNA sex eukaryotic system
eukaryotic life the endosymbiosis event
or the archaeon 8 little bacteria you
know just the whole thing and then of
course emergence of Consciousness and so
on so it seems like definitely there are
sports events where mass amount of
progress was made